Get ready to ugly cry, Marvel fans.
And beware, major Avengers: Infinity War spoilers
ahead.
Guardians of the Galaxy director James Gunn
has shared a heart-shattering detail about
Groot in Infinity War that has has people
absolutely reeling.
On Twitter, Gunn revealed the tree-like Guardian's
final line in the film, uttered just after
Josh Brolin's Thanos snaps his Infinity Gauntlet-rocking
hand to get rid of half the universe's population.
Groot, voiced by Fast and the Furious franchise
star Vin Diesel, was one of the heroes that
disintegrated into a flurry of ashy space
bits, joined by a number of others, including
Chadwick Boseman's Black Panther, Benedict
Cumberbatch's Doctor Strange, Elizabeth Olsen's
Scarlet Witch, and Tom Holland's Spider-Man,
who had what was largely considered the most
agonizing and tear-inducing final moment in
Infinity War.
Until now.
"I am Groot."
A fan asked Gunn on Twitter, "Might be too
soon to ask this, but do you know what Groot's
last line is at the end of the movie?"
Surprisingly, Gunn answered quickly and candidly,
disclosing that Groot's last word was "Dad,"
in reference to Bradley Cooper's Rocket Racoon.
We are Groot, we are broken, and we're not
alone.
One Twitter user responded to Gunn: "That
Groot and Rocket scene devastated my heart
and soul.
I have NEVER imagined a time where a talking
tree calling a talking raccoon dad would be
this much, unironically, sad.
Marvel what have you done to us."
When asked about it, Gunn reiterated that
the line was in the screenplay and that he
didn't make up the answer to the fan on the
spot.
The script in question is the exclusive "Groot
version" that only goes to Gunn and Diesel,
so we'll have to take the director's tweet
reveal at face value.
While Avengers: Infinity War continues to
blaze through box office records, recently
passing the $1 billion milestone in record
time, we'll be quietly sobbing in the corner
about all this.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!